the women of the Gulabi gang are
fighting back against rapists brutal
husbands and corrupt police officers if
necessary using sticks founders Sam Pat
Paul is training her troupe of Indian
women oh boy if someone hits you on the
head she says hold the stick like this
if he attacks from the side like this up
their sticks and they're pink saris are
the hallmarks of the gang from bundle
[ __ ] in southern India oh yeah oh yeah
bomb ha no we're not allowed to defend
ourselves are we not allowed to protect
ourselves so yet done that's not
violence and this is not a weapon it's
only a stick we're not criminals
rhenium on that kibbutz Shanda wotty
pasa Juan and her sister-in-law Kunti
Devi joined the gang five years ago
Chanda what he needed help and the GU
lobbies provided it quickly and without
any complications many women had joined
the gang for the same reason it was to
do with her daughter Shan de Watty
explains the graboid game she ran away
with a boy from another caste she says
for two years I didn't know where she
was when she came back she was three
months pregnant
the boy had simply thrown her out then I
joined the Gulabi gang she says they
tracked the boy down and made them get
married sadly as gulabi Shan de Watty
and Kunti now know how to demand their
rights even though the traditional role
of an indian wife requires her to remain
silent and obey the will of her husband
already a party eighteen-year-old Rachna
Gupta visits Sampat at home she needs
help
her parents in-law and husband are
beating her out the valley and I would
take you like do our duty these are
bruises from being hit with sticks some
Pat explains about that okay so tell me
everything right from the beginning
watch me has been married for two years
conflict with her parents in-law is
getting worse often little things make
them angry wagons beard of an alien my
mother-in-law pulled my hair my
father-in-law grabbed me and forced me
to the ground I started to cry but he
kept on hitting me almost every day
women come to San Pat with their
concerns many are being beaten by their
husbands or forced into arranged
marriages by their own parents
Rodney's mother has known Sam Pat for a
long time she hopes the Gulabi gang will
be able to talk sense into her
daughter's parents and law dig like many
young women in rural India watch me
married when she was very young and soon
had a child
her parents chose her husband for her as
is the tradition in India with only gaya
did you go on I'll be right behind you
Sam Pat says when they marry
Indian women move into their parents
in-laws home they all have to adapt to
the change it's washday at Sam Pat's
place everything here is Gulabi which
means pink but will I be Ponca daddy no
matter where I go I always wear a pink
sari I have a lot of pink saris but
there are at least 50 in my wardrobe
vehicle a vehicle a vehicle of a pink
blue and pink pink bed pink walls pink
skirt steak or
maybe 20 people live in Sam Pat's house
grandchildren and children husband
daughter-in-law did not belong to any
the gulabi boss has five children four
daughters and one son
she herself married when she was 12 and
she had her first child at 15 no idea at
the wedding what was going to happen she
says I didn't know anything about my
future if I would be criticized or
beaten a lot of people beat their wives
after the wedding I only knew that I was
getting married but I was far too young
to really understand that we have my
badge but ago Salter I loved uncle
Johanna cassava o at the Badal sir
police station everyone is waiting from
Rocky's husband to show up he's being
asked to explain why he drinks so much
and beats her Sam that takes charge the
local policeman is not keen to get
involved even the police have come to
respect the gulabi boss she mediates in
most such cases no problem is too
private for her to get involved in
look at the state of you I have no money
for clothes the husband says but you can
afford to buy alcohol and you beat your
wife didn't you also soil your pants he
says he didn't die whether you put that
back David like you can remember that
you didn't hit her
Sam Pat says but you've forgotten that
you soiled your pants and then your wife
is supposed to clean up your filth clean
your soiled pants she doesn't deserve
that
I did that'll be you don't talk nonsense
I packed it all with the wire well if
any media buy an Apple stop drinking
do your work get yourself a job I
promise to stop drinking mother I don't
wanna sign up so now my Ataru view data
you can go now and don't beat her
anymore
do you understand me thank God say it
out loud Lamar yet I won't beat her
anymore
that'd be the right now letteth would
you like that oh no Ron seems to take
the husband's pledge seriously not even
a husband himself so some pet asks the
police to keep an eye on the man if he
misbehaves again she warns him he'll get
a visit from the whole Gulabi gang
some hats youngest daughter Nisha
recently married now she is preparing to
move Sampat chose her husband and her
new family for her
the gulabi boss believes in arranged
marriages in a few days time 20 year old
Nisha will move to the house of her
parents-in-law fall out the foot that
I've never me papa I'm a bit sad because
I'm leaving my mother and father and my
family behind
Nisha says here but that alpaca daresay
latakia devotee Allah little Kosuke melt
that butter picked up if my daughter is
happy in her new family then everything
is okay but I just don't know beforehand
how they will receive her so I says
daddy so double dallara karate super
feel good good today later conclusion
eight ball but when my daughter comes to
visit she will be a stranger in my house
I'll be a log by D in a little Kootenay
gotta soak bit she won't be able to talk
about any problems with her new family
Yoho even I as her mother will be a
stranger for her then but I did Margaret
humbly walk alone I'm a colonic artist
but holding up some part is making her
rounds this time it's a shocking and
tragic case shortly before the mass rape
in Delhi that made headlines around the
world a seven-year-old girl was raped
and killed here in bundle [ __ ] Sampat
asks how the family are doing is the
perpetrator still in jail yes the mother
says but I think he's going to be
released soon
no he won't be Sam Pat says it was a
pretty girl if the perpetrator is ever
released he will never be able to walk
the streets we will tattoo his face
rapist and murderer
Mordechai odekake Omari Jeremy Oh public
OC Calgary or the sloka or Kyle he will
never want anyone to see his face
because people would persecute him
that's how we'll do it from now on
kuchela garage Okara Miguel ma demande
engage a psychotic over such ability I
tell you what not so instead of the
frequent calls for the death penalty for
rapists tattoos
so far the Gulabi gang hasn't resorted
to such methods Sam Pat plans to
officially announce her new vigilante
punishment method to the media soon for
a public holiday be tails goodbyes the
gang women are working on it
- straw figures will serve as rapists
and fraudsters Sam Pat is going to
tattoo their foreheads but symbolically
using charcoal instead of real ink
Sunday after that buddy ahkamaat dulce
we're going to announce it everywhere
the summer loss got back out again
oh yay got cutting if we get our hands
on one of these rapists will tattoo him
immediately
I'm not afraid of the consequences girls
can make the smile even Iggy thorny
bottling our Taconic a VSO so Janet gave
me yourself I never thought I'd have to
do something like this but I believe
it's necessary Sam Potts I
I'll set the high Indian media
frequently report brutal rapes the
United Nations has named India is the
most dangerous place in the world for
girls and young women
Sampat hopes to deter potential rapists
with the tattoo threat look at one
Magdala give pianta to destroy someone's
life and he wants to kill me
I don't care everyone has to die
sometime she says at the demonstration
the straw rapist takes a serious beating
the Gulabi gang want to show that women
cannot be taken for granted in Boonville
can't at least that message is getting
through everyone here knows the women in
pink suddenly the protest parade stops
someone has found a baby abandoned in a
field it's a girl of course many Indian
families consider girl babies a burden
because they will have to provide a
dowry for them one day when they marry
but this baby's in luck the people who
found her want to keep her and the
Gulabi gang will help with the adoption